ça leur reste que marine le pen en
accusant pointant du doigt emmanuel
macron et sa politique responsable selon
elle de l'abstention massive aujourd'hui
près de 68%
c'est un record sous la vème république
est ce que marine le pen elle prend pas
quelque part de la distance par rapport
justement aux résultats du rassemblement
national qui semble moins bon que prévu
oui sont plus que moins bon c'est on en
a parlé dès lors c'est une claque
absolue et puis mais marine le pen moi
je suis je suis assez je me préserve là
dessus parce que j'ai l'impression de
marine le pen quand même très
sincèrement nadège elle est en train de
faire une énorme erreur parce qu'en fait
elle ce présidentialisme marine le pen
est elle a perdu énormément de
conviction on en parle souvent sur la
souveraineté
elle a énormément reculé et je crois
qu'elle n'arrive plus à faire la
jonction finalement à ce qu'avait été
notamment gelé dit récemment de l'ap
ligne 800 sous sarko entre l'identité et
et l'hindi la souveraineté et elle
n'arrive plus à faire ça il se
présidentialise et je pense que
peut-être peut-être que ce soir les très
très mauvais résultats du et rennes sont
en train de marquer le début
finalement de début alors on va pas dire
un naufrage ça serait trop fort
évidemment d'un accident idéologique
tour marine le pen parce qu'elle était
de présidentialiser bon on a vu le débat
d'entre deux tours et ça je pense que ça
va lui courir après un moment est
effectivement marine le pen là dessus
moi je pense qu'à un moment donné à
vouloir se présidentialiser comme ça
elle risque de fracture est énorme en ce
bloc là qu'elle a actuellement et de pas
être clair sur les sujets sous pour nt1
est dit dans le titre d'identité oui
parce que c'est le fonds de commerce du
fn mais sur les sujets de souveraineté
marine le pen elle joue très gros nadège
par rapport à ça et d'ailleurs c'est
pour ça peut être aussi qu'eric zemmour
pourrait peut-être prendre tangente par
rapport à ça puisqu'il fait mieux cette
jonction l'art entre les deux et ils
marine le pen aujourd'hui peut être pour
analyser rester sur l'actualité du soir
je pense que peut-être la claque c'est
qu'au moment donné il ya des gens qui
sont en train de comprendre aussi que
marine le pen est quelque part
présidentielle on va dire men stream et
que ce même s'ils misent à sion
finalement de sa candidature pourrait
lui coûter cher parce qu'on est qu'elle
est encore un élection présidentielle et
c'est très très très très long un an
nadège